[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy it has now come to light that his
Director of the FBI
Robert Mueller who is currently the
special counsel looking for any dirt he
can find on President Trump
presided over the 2012 removal of all
counter terror training materials that
made any mention of Islam and jihad in
connection with terrorism since then our
law enforcement and intelligence
officials have been blundering along in
self-imposed darkness about the
motivating ideology behind the jihad
threat now this turns out to be Robert
Mueller's doing in February 2012 the
Obama administration purged more than a
thousand documents and presentations
from counter terror training material
for the FBI and other agencies this
material was discarded at the demand of
Muslim groups which had deemed it
inaccurate or offensive to Muslims
now this purge was several years in the
making and I myself was inadvertently
the one who touched it off in August
2010 I gave a talk on Islam in Jihad to
the FBI's Joint Terrorism Task Force one
of many such talks I gave to government
agencies and military groups in those
years now while some had counseled me to
keep these talks quiet so as to avoid
attracting the ire of the Hamas linked
Council on american-islamic relations or
care the possibility of that pressure
seemed to me to make it all the more
important to announce that I had been
there so as to show that the US
government was not going to take
dictation from a group linked to Hamas
and the Muslim Brotherhood as it turned
out however those who had urged silence
were correct for the Obama
administration was indeed disposed to
take dictation from care care sent a
series of letters to Mueller and others
demanding that I be dropped as a
counter-terror trainer and the
organization even started a coalition
echoing the demand and Jesse Jackson and
other leftist luminaries joined it at
the FBI Mueller made no public comment
on cares
demand and so it initially appeared that
Kara's effort had failed but I was never
again invited to provide counter-terror
training for any government agency after
having done so fairly regularly for the
previous five years Kara's campaigned to
keep me from taking part in
counter-terror training was of course
not personal they targeted me simply
because I told the truth
just as they would target anyone else
who dared to do so although a Muller was
publicly silent now we know that he was
not unresponsive and the Islamic
supremacists and their leftist allies
did not give up in the summer and fall
of 2011 the online tech journal Wired
published several exposes by the
far-left journalist Spencer Ackerman who
took the FBI to task for training
material that spoke forthrightly and
truthfully about the nature and
magnitude of the jihad threat in a
typical Sally from one of these exposes
Ackerman condemned the training material
for intimating that mainstream American
Muslims were quote likely to be
terrorist sympathizers now certainly all
the mainstream Muslim organizations
condemn al Qaeda and 9/11 however some
of the foremost of those organizations
such as asana mossack know the MSA care
and others have links of various kinds
to Hamas and the Muslim Brotherhood a
mainstream Muslim spokesman in the US
Ground Zero mosque Imam Feisal Abdul
Rauf refused to condemn Hamas until it
became too politically damaging for him
not to do so cares Nihad Awad openly
declared his support for Hamas in 1994
other mainstream Muslim spokesmen in the
u.s. such as Obama's ambassador to the
Organization of Islamic Cooperation
Rashad Hussain and media gadfly Hussein
Ibish
have praised and defended Sami al-arian
the confessed leader of yet another
Jihad terror group Palestinian Islamic
Jihad do these men and organizations
represent a tiny minority of extremists
that actually does not express the
opinions of the broad mainstream of
Muslims in this country maybe but
there's something no counterparts no
individuals of comparable influence or
groups of comparable size that have not
expressed sympathy for some Islamic
terror group nonetheless in the face of
Akram
reports the FBI went into full retreat
in September 2011 it announced that it
was dropping one of the programs that
Ackerman had zeroed in on then on
October 19 2011
Farhana Cara of Muslim advocates who had
complained for years about supposed
Muslim profiling and entrapment sent a
letter to John Brennan who is then the
assistant to the President on national
security for Homeland Security and
counterterrorism the letter was signed
not just by Cara but by the leaders of
virtually all the significant Islamic
groups in the u.s. 57 Muslim Arab and
South or Asian organizations many again
with ties to Hamas and the Muslim
Brotherhood including care the Islamic
Society of North America the Muslim
American Society the Islamic circle of
North America Islamic Relief USA and the
Muslim Public Affairs Council the letter
denounced what it characterized as US
government agencies use of biased false
and highly offensive training materials
about Muslims and Islam it criticized
the FBI's use of biased experts and
training materials Cara complained that
my books could be found in the FBI's
library at the FBI training academy in
Quantico Virginia that a reading list
accompanying a PowerPoint presentation
by the FBI's law enforcement
communications unit recommended my book
the truth about Mohammed and that in
July 2010 I presented a two-hour seminar
on the belief system of Islamic
jihadists to the Joint Terrorism Task
Force in Tidewater Virginia and
presented a similar lecture to the US
Attorney's anti-terrorism Advisory
Council which is co-hosted by the FBI's
Norfolk field office now these were
supposed to be terrible things because I
was supposed to be bigoted and hateful
but many of the examples Cara adduced of
bigoted and distorted materials involved
statements that were not actually
bigoted and distorted at all but simply
accurate what was distorted was Cara's
representation of them for instance Hera
stated this a 2006 FBI intelligence
report stating that individuals who
convert to Islam are on the path to
becoming homegrown Islamic extremists if
they
exhibit any of the following behavior
wearing traditional Muslim attire
growing facial hair frequent attendance
at a mosque or a prayer group travel to
a Muslim country increased activity in a
pro Muslim social group or political
cause now note the FBI intelligence
report that Kara purported to be
describing did not actually say that
converts to Islam were necessarily on
the path to becoming extremists if they
wore traditional Muslim attire grew
facial hair and frequently attended a
mosque
it simply included these behaviors among
a list of 14 indicators to identify an
individual going through the
radicalization process others included
travel without obvious source of funds
suspicious purchases of bomb-making
paraphernalia or weapons large transfer
of funds from or to overseas and
formation of operational cells Kara
selectively quoted and misrepresented
the list to give the impression that the
FBI was saying that devout observance of
Islam led inevitably and in every case
to extremism
despite the factual accuracy of the
material about which they were
complaining the Muslim groups signing
the letter demanded that the task force
purge all federal government trainings
of materials of these supposedly biased
materials and implement a mandatory
retraining program for FBI agents u.s.
army officers and all federal state and
local law enforcement who have been
subjected to biased training they asked
for more as well to ensure that all law
enforcement officials would learn about
Islam in Jihad only what the signatories
through this letter wanted them to learn
Brennan immediately complied numerous
books and presentations that gave a
perfectly accurate view of Islam in
Jihad were purged but it wasn't just
Brennan now we know that it was Mueller
all along both Brennan and Mueller of
course are part of the same Washington
establishment that has wholeheartedly
endorsed the idea that honest analysis
of jihadist motives is Islamophobia the
longer our military and intelligence
apparatus subscribes to this view the
worse off we will be
I'm Robert Spencer
[Music]